congratulations on being accepted to
Harvard I'm Rakesh Khurana I'm the Dean
of the college I know there must be a
lot of thoughts going through your mind
whether this is the right place for you
or whether you belong here let me assure
you we see something in you you might
not even see in yourself and you will
find your home here I feel like Harvard
is my home it just could not feel more
natural to call Harvard my home I just
can't help it you can act like yourself
at Harvard if you're a prim and proper
person then be that all the time but if
you're not that's cool too the minute
you realize this is your home is when
you really get to know a lot of people
and even feel like I became more of
myself at Harvard than I did in high
school and Harvard definitely I think
does a great job of letting you blossom
into the person that you want to be so
one of my favorite parts about freshman
year was getting to eat annamaria you
can literally sit at a different table
every day and meet people from across
the country it's very warm and welcoming
the first week we had a ton of
activities fairs and a ton of just
people just reaching out to I'm the
freshman and trying to get them involved
people are so willing to really engage
and get to know you
there's 450 different
extracurriculars on campus sports or
music or culture and if you don't find
that within that broad range of
Harvard's more than willing to help you
start up your own when I got here I
realize that there wasn't yet a group
for asian-american women and so I've
decided to start one Harvard has a lot
of school pride and I think that shows
mostly through the houses housing days
is certainly a Harvard holiday it is
when the freshmen learn about which of
the 12 houses that they will be placed
what it means is that you gain a new
sense of identity
you get to have 300 new friends and so
if you really want that community it's
there for you I found so many different
students who I could relate to the
people here are amazing no matter what
socioeconomic background you're from
you're a first generation student you're
like a ninth generation student no
matter what your beliefs are matter what
your hobbies are no matter if you're
from a small city Massachusetts or a
Township in Africa you're gay you're
straight you're transgender you want me
to teach you idiot doctor whether you
like sciences whether you like history
you will find a home here at Harvard you
can find a home at Harvard you can find
your home at Harvard there's always
going to be an inclusive home here at
Harvard
you